there are places in the Multiverse that
human beings were never meant to find
worlds populated with swarms of crawling
spiders isolated dimensional prisons
were faceless corpses mimic the living
and Realms bathed in the purest Darkness
were a glimmer of Light May reveal more
than what a visitor might ever want to
see these places serve to remind us that
every one of us is before any other
essential quality of our collective
experience alone every human mind is an
isolated incident struggling to make
sense of every environment while hoping
to find common ground with the other
people in our lives we strive to
understand others and be understood but
sadly it is often the case that we must
interact with fellow human beings whose
motivations seem alien to us all too
frequently we are surrounded by people
we cannot relate to in situations we
have little control over and even if we
make attempts to articulate ourselves
there will always be an insurmountable
Gulf between the limits of our
experience and others as far as each of
us knows we are the only free willed
individuals in the cosmos and even the
nature of that Free Will is deeply in
question while many of us become
overwhelmed by these bigger questions
and are forced to confront our inherent
loneliness there is an instinct to turn
to unfeeling things for answers surely
the vast expanse of creation that made
us must have done so for a reason most
of who asked that question spend their
entire lives waiting for confirmation of
that reason they reach out for something
or somewhere that they are meant to be
it is only the vanishing rare few that
find it an unmistakable answer in an
unspeakable place a terrifying Vista of
Madness that all that screams you will
never belong
scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
has found himself in places like these
more times than he is able to count he
has seen the spiders the room of corpses
that mimic human activity and has peered
through the darkness assisted by a
flashlight and seeing only the smiling
face of a humanoid monster there are
dozens more frightening and unsettling
universes that scp-507 has encountered
and all known instances have been
archived in document
scp-507-3b any one of the innumerable
Horrors that this otherwise ordinary
human male has endured would send a
shiver down the spine of the best of us
but unfortunately this is little Comfort
to a CPE 507 facing down The Madness of
the abyss and returning intact starts to
become less triumphant when it is a
weekly sometimes daily occurrence the
dimension Hopper can barely have a
moment of Peace in this life as his
irregular shifts into different
realities occur without any warning and
all the research that the foundation has
done on scp-507 seems to indicate that
there will never be an end to these
trips into the infinite but no end does
not necessarily imply the lack of a
beginning the tragic existence of
scp-507 could not have started without a
cons and part of the foundation's goal
in containing
scp-507 is to discern an explanation for
the humanoid signature unstable mode of
interdimensional travel so far the
experiments have raised one burning
question after another with scp-507
himself having difficulty recounting
some of the stranger aspects of the
dimension he hops into and in a grander
sense what it might all mean but the
foundation has no choice but to listen
intently to scp-507 and take notes on
everything he says in regards to his
condition after all the phenomenon of
Leaping to other worlds primarily affect
the dimension Hopper himself and can
really only be under stood through a
thorough understanding of the subject
over the course of many interviews with
scp-507 the research team has pieced
together what they believe might be the
definitive history of The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper from his native reality
to the flux of ever-changing hellscapes
that occupies his current days while it
is impossible to verify due to the
imperfect nature of memory and the
countless traumas suffered by a cp507
the foundation believes that this record
can be used as a case study for further
investigation into the Multiverse itself
on a less practical level the interviews
can help the foundation to improve
containment for scp-507 and make sure
that his existence is as lacking in
unnecessary suffering as possible we're
going back to the beginning to the
earliest dimensional hops that scp-507
can remember in detail considering the
persistent nature of scp-507's
anomalous capabilities it was hardly
surprising for the foundation to learn
that the humanoid did not have a
conventional childhood 507 has never
made any mention of identifiable
biological parents nor of any Grade
School Educational facility public or
private in the absence of these markers
of normalcy
scp-507 describes spending an
indeterminate amount of his formative
years in a Fantastical realm known as
limonora though it has apparently been
decades since scp-507 has hopped into
luminora he was able to describe the
dimension in great detail a grassy plane
of a run with red honeycomb standing
stones that seemed to sing with
thousands of beautiful voices as the
wind blew through them the Skies of
luminora were colored a velvety bluish
purple which never got any dimmer than a
commercial night light there were
shallow streams of spring water that
seemed to run in all directions
regardless of elevation there were also
dangers in
flocks of swooping Birds which scp-507
described as having the appearance of
skinless vultures these vultures would
often attempt to capture scp-507 and
bring him to a location known as the
dawnwell as one might expect 507 was
never actually apprehended by the
creatures but insists that these were
more than ordinary Birds of Prey
vultures don't hunt for live human
children being scavengers after all it
has also been made clear that 507 was
the only human of any sort in luminora
this has led the researchers to conclude
that he most likely wasn't born in that
reality and had previously hopped there
from a dimension of origin that remains
inaccessible due to his lack of memories
during infancy the dimension Hopper
claims that his best friend finnicker
always protected him from these avian
threats finnicker was another creature
native to limonora who resembled an
anomalous crustacean the size of a large
dog covered in what scp-50 007 believed
to be a coat of tufted brown fur when
fending off the vultures vinegar carried
a heavy cudgel in one of his claws the
blunt instrument was said to be carved
from the same material as the musical
Standing Stones additionally 507 has
remarked that the inside of vinegar
shell was mostly Hollow and could be
used as a shelter and resting place for
the young Dimension Hopper as long as he
had the continued friendship of the
creature many researchers who have taken
statements from scp-507 regarding the
menorah have reflexively come to view
the unconfirmed dimension and 507's
experiences therein as the product of a
wild imagination made more Vivid due to
a traumatic upbringing on the other hand
scp-507 insists that limonora is not a
psychological coping mechanism and is in
fact just as real as all the other
dimensions he has hopped into it is
difficult to dismiss his account
entirely as no matter how many times
scp-507 is asked about luminora and how
far apart the interviews are the details
of the account never seem to deviate
from what had previously been
established during his time in limonora
which may have spanned more than a year
507 has stated that he was the happiest
that he had ever been whenever he wasn't
avoiding the vultures of The Well of
dawn 507 passed Time by listening to the
music from The Standing Stones surfing
the erratic currents of the shallow
streams and learning rudimentary carving
techniques with finnicker in some ways
limonora was a paradise for a child
there was no homework or chores and
whenever it was safe he could play
outside as much as he wanted it wasn't
until one terrible night that everything
about his isolated existence changed for
the worst while falling asleep inside
vinegar's shell
scp-507 experienced a random dimensional
shift to a deep and forbidding Forest at
first he thought thought this new
reality was a dream as it was abnormally
dark and Misty nothing like lemonora
then he saw them the so-called mammal
men
scp-507 remembered their chattering
teeth long and orange like beaver's
teeth as well as the leathery pale skin
that covered their misshapen bodies the
mammal men roared and hissed making
unnatural noises as they chewed into the
trees the sound of it all was very
distressing for young
scp-507 who began to flee from the
strange humanoids into the nearby bushes
he cried out for finnicker hoping that
his friend would arrive and protect him
but it didn't happen and try as he might
it seemed as though he couldn't wake up
from this nightmare it wasn't a
nightmare at all in fact but a true
dimensional shift from which there could
be no easy return terrified for reasons
Beyond his comprehension the young
dimensional Hopper continued to cry out
for his only friend there was a sudden
crack and allowed whoosh as one of the
great trees of the forest came toppling
down in his Direction
scp-507 braced himself for the
inevitable impact but it never came he
was in what appeared to be a city now
and it was the middle of the day crowds
of human beings surrounded him and the
sounds of automobiles and phone calls
drowned his mind in the cacophony it was
a total sensory overload compared to
limonora and being exposed to it after
having such a harrowing experience in
the forest Dimension caused scp-507 to
break down into tears he continued to
weep and call out for finnicker but his
crustacean friend was several Worlds
Away now when the authorities eventually
arrived given a call about a lost child
scp-507 was brought to the nearby police
station the officers tried to ask
scp-507 questions presumably about where
his parents were or where his home was
but 507 recalls being unable to
understand the language they were
speaking and thus there was was no hope
of communication the adults seemed
equally frustrated and tried speaking to
the child in a number of different
languages eventually when no parent or
Guardian appeared to claim the child it
was determined that scp-507 would be
placed in foster care from their scp-507
was given to a family that soon became
his legal Guardians he was homeschooled
on many of the basic subjects of Science
and Math and learned the English
language through constant tutoring while
his new parents and siblings were
willing to entertain his stories of
luminora and finnicker they believed it
was little more than the fantasy of an
imaginary friend throughout the rest of
his youth
scp-507 experienced no unusual Dimension
hopping and began to live a relatively
normal and unremarkable life at a
certain point he even began to believe
that limonora never existed none of the
other children he knew had ever
experienced something like it the fact
that they would constantly remind him of
in their ruthless teasing even so
scp-507 entered his teen years as a
shockingly normal individual given the
circumstances while the foundation has
never been able to verify the names and
identities of his foster family members
mostly because scp-507 has been
reluctant to divulge any related
information his seeming loyalty to
keeping the people who raised him
anonymous is proof enough that this
chapter of his life was not fabricated
according to scp-507's testimony the
involuntary shifting began to reoccur
not long after he had gone through
puberty the sudden disappearance is
worried his family and many times they
believed that he had attempted to run
away from home this also had an impact
on his social and educational
development as maintaining both
friendships and good grades in high
school were difficult when he could
disappear for days and weeks at a time
the vast majority of these dimensional
leaps are uneventful Beyond The Strain
they put on
scp-507's efforts at a normal life but
one in particular has left a lasting
impact on 507 it was during a Halloween
block party in his senior year when
scp-507 shifted away during an attempt
to refill his punch he blinked in shock
to find himself in limonora once more
but it was not as he had left it the sky
was a deep shade of maroon and cracked
like a glass surface from there these
cracks spilled sand like rain onto the
now desolate Plains and dried up Rivers
The Standing Stones were mostly broken
and there was no wind to conduct them
into their song the teenage 507 wandered
around this ruined limonora in disbelief
the Fantastical place he remembered had
been real for his entire life but now it
was dead if that wasn't traumatizing
enough nothing could prepare him for
what awaited at The Well of dawn near
the strange pit of emanated sunlight was
the rotted Sun bleach shell of a massive
crustacean vinegar 507 barely had any
time to take in the sight of his
long-lost friend before he was returned
to the roof of the Halloween party that
was the last time he ever saw the world
of lemonorah but it was far far from the
most horrific sites that the Multiverse
would have to offer want to own an SCP
of your own go to scpswag.com for
premium anomalous merchandise now go
check out scp-507 reluctant Dimension
Hopper and can scp-096 chase its victims
across the Multiverse for more
interdimensional Adventures from scp-507